It's weird to say there's good news. Anytime
someone has died of corona virus, that it
doesn't seem right to say that. But I don't
know how else to explain this other than to say
we received a positive piece of news regarding a
tragic corona virus death. A Corona virus vaccine
trial participant got Corona virus and died
from complications. The news we got is that this
patient had received the placebo, not the vaccine,
which from the standpoint of vaccine development,
is a good piece of news, although it doesn't make
this death any less tragic. So I'll catch you up
on on what happened. One of the corona virus
vaccines being developed. That seems to be,
I guess we'll call it one of the top three
sort of candidates. Is the Oxford vaccine
being developed and tested by AstraZeneca, the
pharmaceutical company? This is the trial that
I told you. I don't know if it was four, six,
seven weeks ago that was being put on hold
because there was a serious health incident for
one of the people who received the vaccine. This
happens in vaccine trials and they put the
entire vaccine trial on hold in phase three.
Tragically, that person died of complications
from Corona virus, which they contracted,
and it was a Brazilian participant. And that's
a horrible thing. What we've now learned is
that this participant did not have the corona
virus vaccine. They were in the placebo arm
of the vaccine trial. One of the important things
that's done in these trials is that not everybody
gets the vaccine. Some people get the placebo and
they don't know it in order to compare the effects
of the vaccine versus the placebo, remembering
that this is a phase three trial. So what we're
looking at is not safety. Phase one and two has
already dealt with safety as the primary thing
that is being tested. Phase three is looking at
efficacy. Now, of course, if the person who died
had received the actual vaccine, you would
have two things to look at. Number one, what
does it say about the efficacy of the vaccine?
Of course, no vaccine is 100 percent effective.
But number two, was the death related
to an adverse reaction to the vaccine
that would put the development of the entire
vaccine in question? In this particular case,
it was not the vaccine that caused this adverse
event because the person received the placebo
and indeed, it was a complication to corona virus.
And the reality is that in a Phase three trial
with 30 or 40 thousand people, if you follow those
folks for months, by sheer odds, there are people
in that group who would die or who would have a
serious health incident. In this particular case,
the person actually got coronavirus. They had
received the placebo and not the vaccine. Now,
this is why we do trials. There are times when
an event would happen regardless of the vaccine
in this particular case. This is an individual
who actually got the the the the virus that the
vaccine is being tested against. It's very sad
from the individual standpoint. It is, in a sense,
reassuring from the standpoint of vaccine
safety. Now, there is also this discussion of
if the person had gotten the vaccine and
still got coronavirus, would that mean that
it's a bad vaccine and it wouldn't? It wouldn't.
Again, when you're testing 30 to 40000 people,
vaccines are not 100 percent effective. They are
not expected to be. You don't need them to be.
Order to be effective at the herd or larger
population level. But it does again raise
these issues of the efficacy of giving placebos
to people. And this is a well-established area
of medical ethics. The question of at what point
would you say the placebo is no longer ethical?
Because the real vaccine or the real
treatment is clearly so effective. And
that is a well-established area of medical ethics
that is sort of beyond the scope of this program.
I don't have an answer specifically in this case,
but in general, placebos start to be questioned
when there is a standard of care already
existing that is better in this case. We're
testing vaccines against nothing. The vaccine is
not a treatment and thus it's a very different
sort of situation. And and then again, just as
a reminder, phase three is not about safety.
It's about efficacy. But yes, when you give
the vaccine to 30 or 40000 thousand people,
you may get data about safety that you didn't
necessarily get in a smaller phase two trial.
All of this goes to say what? That we are still
in process looking at various vaccine candidates.
We still don't know how long will these
vaccines, presuming they work, confer immunity.
How effective will they be? Is it a
40 percent effective vaccine? Is it
70 percent effective? And then, by the way,
at the tail end of it, we really can't ignore
that. There's a large portion of the population
in the United States that doesn't plan to get a
vaccine when it's available, that doesn't have an
interest in being vaccinated. And how that affects
our ability to get to herd immunity is both a
mathematical question, a scientific question,
and really a sociocultural question as
well, which we will continue to discuss.
Let me know your thoughts on this latest
news and your sort of outlook on the vaccine.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman. Make
sure you are following me there.